also wenn das da ist ich werde es direkt
auspacken ich werde alles dransetzen
dass dieses produkt wirklich ankommt und
wenn ich dieses produkt nicht spätestens
in vier wochen in einem video zeige dann
dann höre ich auch mit youtube leute und
bevor ich es vergesse ganz uns wichtig
bitte abonnieren kanal wir sind bald
eine million also vielleicht schaffen
wir es diesen monat ist wenn megageil
deswegen geh da ganz schnell und ich
verspreche euch jetzt mal gab es auch
eine menge coole videos ist dann lohnt
sich das ich würde mich sehr freuen
jetzt geht es weiter hey leute was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut
heute ein video auf das ich mich ja
jetzt seit einem monat sage ich mal
vorbereitet habe ich hab's euch
eigentlich auch versprochen und ich
fühle mich auch ein bisschen schlecht
muss ich sagen immer noch weil ich es
immer noch nicht so durchgezogen habe
wie es halt eigentlich letztes jahr
schon machen wollte wenn wir mal ganz
kurz zurückblicken ich habe ungefähr
genau heute vor einem jahr ein video
gemacht wo ich das teuerste produkt auch
ganz ruhig gestellt habt das war halt
damals so eine massage stuhl für 1000
irgendwas keine ahnung den genauen preis
weiß ich gar nicht mehr es war auf jeden
fall schon sehr sehr teuer und das für
ein massagestuhl aber ich habe mir
gedacht das wird oft angefragt und du
kannst du zwei videos raus machen
deswegen macht es einfach mal wird schon
irgendwie lustig werden das problem war
dann im endeffekt der ist dann beim zoll
hängengeblieben ich habe da auch mal so
ein ganze story video zu gemacht wo ich
halte diese ganze story erklärt haben
könnt ihr euch auch sehr gerne mal
anschauen falls ihr das nicht schon
getan habt und dann dieses video weiter
schauen aber heute ziehen wir das
wirklich noch mal durch und ich werde
euch versprechen egal wie hoch die
kosten sind die da noch auf mich
zukommen wenn ich da irgendwelche zoll
gewinnzahlen ist da gibt es wirklich so
viel quatsch da denkt man gar nicht dran
was halt noch passieren oder was schief
gehen kann wenn ein produkt ein großes
teures produkt aus china oder wo auch
immer das herkommt nach deutschland
geschickt wird so ganz leicht ist es
halt nicht ich habe euch gestern noch
finsterer miene fragt leute schicken wir
mal produkte zu und das haben sehr viele
gemacht und wir schauen uns jetzt mal an
ich werde selber natürlich auch noch ein
bisschen suchen und dann werden wir im
endeffekt das teuerste bestellen wobei
ich mir noch eine rege gesetzt habe und
zwar keine elektronik produkte einfach
weil es gut sein kann dass es irgendwie
ein laptop gibt oder so den man aber
auch ganz stumpf in deutschland überall
kaufen kann
das ist dann halt
wie langweilig meinte ein packender
austestet jahr ist ein geiles ding für
2000 euro muss ja auch gut sein ich
hoffe das war steht ja im endeffekt ja
auch nur unterhaltung und wir schauen
jetzt mal in die nachrichten rein und
ich schaue mir die produkte an alter wir
haben jetzt hier 40 minuten später das
hat ganz schön lange gedauert ich würde
alle meine instagram nachrichten ob
fenster markieren das alex wie kann da
gern mal vorbeischauen durchgegangen und
habe die teuersten sachen rausgefiltert
weil ich habe echt keinen bock selber
die ganze zeit zu suchen das dauert so
ewig wird man da irgendetwas findet was
halbwegs teuer ist ich will jetzt gar
nicht mehr lange daran ich habe jetzt
die 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 teuersten produkte die
mir zugeschickt wurden ich habe selber
noch ein bisschen geschaut ich hab
nichts teures gefunden
vielleicht findet ihr noch irgendwas wie
gesagt laptops ziel nicht dazu
wobei ich auch keine form gefunden habe
der teurer war als das was wir jetzt am
ende haben hier war das erste produkt
was mir geschickt wurde und zwar wehrte
es geahnt ein massagesessel also für 623
euro schon viel finde ich für so ein
produkt was man mal eben bei bis
bestellt kommt sogar zwischen dem 28
dezember an es ist allerdings nicht der
massage stuhl den wir letztes jahr
bestellt haben den habe ich nicht mehr
gefunden ich glaube dann gibt sich mehr
der wahrheit auch noch ein bisschen
teurer aber das produkt ist noch längst
nicht das teuerste es geht noch besser
und zwar machen wir mal hier mit weiter
muss ich jetzt sagen klar ist auch
technik aber ich habe es einfach noch
mit reingenommen einen curved game
monitor und ich finde gut also der schon
fest
geil eigentlich wäre es so zum
videoschnitt für mich als zweiter
monitor kostet hier 746 euro
ich weiß nicht ich will mal ganz kurz
aus nachschauen das hört sich für mich
allerdings schon nach dem ziemlich
teuren preis an dem star jetzt hier
gerade auf amazon und die haben wir auch
so köpplinger für 265 also 704 monitor
ba habe jetzt auch noch nie gesehen so
in jedem laden das ist wirklich so teuer
sein kann ich glaube wenn ich jetzt
konkret nach dem suchen würde bayerisch
dann würde ich dann auf jeden fall noch
günstiger bekommen weil es da immer
verschiedene anbieter gibt oder so das
ist praktisch und algorithmus der immer
ganz viele neue produkte dar ein ballett
und auch irgendwie manchmal zu viel zu
überteuerten preisen das heißt dein tipp
wenn ihr da irgendwas bestellt schaut
immer noch mal genau ob das produkt
nicht irgendwo dann auch günstiger gibt
war bei mir schon sehr oft so aber diese
746 euro wert ist gedacht sind natürlich
noch längst nicht das höchste machen wir
weiter und haben wir als nächstes 753
euro
na gut dass jetzt auch ein bisschen
langweilig
mit sondern einen mountainbike praktisch
gut keine ahnung brauche ich nicht zum
glück ist es das auch nicht also dass
nicht das teuerste wobei man hier sogar
sagen muss expressversand 17 euro also
es wäre sogar bis heute in einer woche
wäre dass da gewesen was nice gewesen
wäre super schnell da gewesen
carsten da muss dann müssen wir noch mal
um die rechtschreibung durchgehen
so habe ich das wort auch noch nie
gesehene g westen liegen also da komme
jetzt gehört dann gar nicht klar die
beste alter was ist da schiefgelaufen
gut nächstes produkt wir haben hier eine
14 kl gold komfort corp chain mäckler
701 40 euro das wäre auch so eine sache
die würde ich da nicht bestellt selbst
wenn das jetzt das teuerste werk wenn es
also um schmuck geht das bestellte ich
ja sicher nicht für 781 euro bayerisch
da gehe ich ein juwelier und fragte anna
guth der shop hat eigentlich eine gute
bewertung aber man kann sich dann
natürlich auch schnell dann denken okay
das ist halt einfach abzog und das ding
ist im endeffekt zehn euro wert alter
krass auch dezember 8 uhr bis 20 uhr
wir haben heute schon den dritten das
heißt noch im sind die geradezu schnell
das finde ich richtig gut okay aber das
ist natürlich auch noch nicht das
endprodukt wir machen weiter und haben
hier was sehr interessantes habe ich vor
dem zuschauer zugeschickt bekommen ein
tumor in tausend windrad also eine
windturbine und hier kann man wirklich
sehen das ding ist riesig also was da
ist jetzt natürlich kein riesen windrad
aber das ist zum teil für den eigenen
garten denke ich mal um selber strom zu
generieren bin ich extrem cool also wenn
ich später irgendwann mal mein eigenes
haus haben oder so immer noch solche
videos macht bestelle ich das auf jeden
fall mal um das dann auch zu testen ob
das wirklich klappt weil es gibt ja so
ein paar leute die haben so was wirklich
im garten stehen da wundere ich mich
wirklich nur so über diesen geringen
versand 11 euro das kann ja eigentlich
nicht aus china kommen sondern fährt das
ding vielleicht sind 250 euro versand
hier schon mit einberechnet wer weiß
aber ein sehr sehr interessantes produkt
hätte ich niemals gedacht dass es so was
hier wird sogar auch expressversand
krass bis dienstag
okay das ist es auch nicht wir machen
weiter und haben hier ein scooter für
803 euro
warte mal war das windrad gerade nicht
teurer ist ja auch egal auf jeden fall
dieses gute wort mir zugeschickt wollte
ich mal kurz danach schauen maximal 25
km/h
ich hatte meinen eigenen
gut hat der ist 35 gefahren der ist dann
leider in deutschland nicht legal
benutzbare funktioniert auch irgendwie
nicht mehr da ist der akku ab und der
liegt nicht mehr sehr schade
und der hat glaube ich damals so 400
euro gekostet wobei ich den netterweise
auch zugeschickt bekommen habe sollte
ich eigentlich ein video mit machen das
produkt kann man danach habe ich nie
wieder was vom verkäufer gehört keine
ahnung wieso also 803 euro stufe hier
sehr sehr teuer ein ich denke den gibt
es auf jeden fall günstiger und jetzt
kommen wir zu einem produkt das sich
wirklich nirgendwo günstiger gefunden
habe das ist schon sehr sehr günstig
weil ich das schon mal auf youtube
gesehen habe und es hat sogar mal 1700
euro gekostet und wir haben es jetzt
hier für 941 euro ich weiß nicht ob ich
das auf youtube gesehen habt das kann
auch gut sein dass das sogar in meinem
letzten video von ungefähr heute vor
einem jahr wo ich das gleiche gemacht
habe schon drin war ich meine es wenn
mal deutlich teurer gewesen wir haben
hier trotzdem knapp 1000 euro 941 euro
und das ist finde ich schon so ein
produkt also eigentlich genial wenn man
sich hier diese bilder anschaut guck mal
wie schön das aussieht ist ja auch eine
klima dann drinnen klimaanlage wäre
natürlich nicht schlecht nennen und bei
dem produkt habe ich mir das wirklich
gedacht einkommen knapp 1000 euro das
das lohnt sich das dann auch auszupacken
und da freue ich mich drauf und ich
hoffe es gibt keine komplikationen und
wir können das wirklich so schnell wie
möglich machen
ihr werdet auch ihr sehen kommt zwischen
18 und 27 dezember also wenn das da ist
ich werde es direkt auspacken ich werde
alles dransetzen dass dieses produkt
wirklich ankommt und wenn ich dieses
produkt nicht spätestens in vier wochen
in einem video zeige dann dann höre ich
auf mit youtube also deswegen ihr könnt
mit ihr könnt mir jetzt wirklich glauben
das produkt wird demnächst ausgepackt
und merkt euch den satz als das ist
jetzt hier kein gelaber das dingen wird
ankommt ich schwöre es euch und ich
werde es auspacken zwar nicht hier in
meinem garten sondern bei meinen eltern
weil die haben wir keinen garten auch
mit stromanschluss sogar dann brauche
ich eigentlich auch noch im bett was ich
da rein stellen kann kommen hier kann
man es auch sehen erste blaue eröffnet
also da kommt auf jeden fall luft rein
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie genau ich
glaube das hat auch stromanschluss habe
ich ja gerade schon gesagt die aufnahme
ist kathi abgebrochen und jetzt würde
ich sagen
dann wollen wir mal ich bin halt am
überlegen kauf ich das mit paypal oder
mit kreditkarte wird kreditkarte
vorsichtshalber 900 euro
egal ich mache gerade also das ist das
muss jetzt einfach mal das ist in
ordnung
11 euro versand kommt noch mit drauf
jetzt machen wir noch mal folgendes auch
ein kleiner trick für euch hier gibt es
eine seite da kann man also provozieren
sagt den geben wir jetzt hier mal ein
und ja der rabatt könig hat zugeschlagen
wir haben jetzt einfach 450 euro gespart
knapp das ist doch schon mal gut jetzt
sind es nur noch 900 euro also das lohnt
sich schaut euch diese rabatt kann wenn
es wahrscheinlich fünf prozent gekriegt
über fünf prozent rabatt kann ich kann
jetzt hier auch ratenkauf machen 1 40
euro im monat mit klar da habe ich alle
auf letztens wurde ich mit klarna das
war ganz blöd habe ich irgendwas
übersehen dann kam so ein
inkassounternehmen musik wird sie 80
euro zahlen anstatt zehn ja weil ich
irgendwo zehn euro nicht bezahlt habe
deswegen teile ich jetzt immer direkt
ist irgendwie viel besser ich werde das
jetzt kaufen ihr werdet sehen ich kann
euch hier sonst auch noch mal die
bestätigung einbinden oder so glaubt mir
meine worte dieses produkt wird es bald
auf einem youtube kanal zu sehen geben
in spätestens vier wochen menschen
angekommen ist ich werde alles
dransetzen und das passiert nicht wieder
so einen scheiß wie letztes jahr dann
werde ich trotzdem durchziehen selbst
wer dann noch 500 euro extra kosten auf
mich zukommt dann würde ich sagen wir
sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder gibt
es ein neues video und und ich kann euch
hier sehr gerne von meiner visa card
oder paypal je nachdem wie ich soll ich
machen hier diesen betrag einbinden das
ist wirklich runtergegangen ist damit
ihr das schon mal seht also leute das
war's morgen 19 uhr neues video
abonniert den kanal haut rein
[Musik]